[Music]
the kardashian kids make a splash with
their own car wash
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot it might be a
lot but we can't get enough of seeing
northwest and penelope disick taking
tick-tock by storm
[Music]
ten-year-old penelope and nine-year-old
north seem to be having a blast creating
content to ellie golding's song lights
it's all fun for the cousins as they put
in a little elbow work cleaning off a
black range rover and check out peace
striking a pose like her mama kourtney
kardashian
[Music]
this car wash brings back memories from
season one of the kardashians when chris
and kylie jenner wanted to take the kids
to the happiest place on earth this says
express wash nine dollars oh that's the
one i bought i'm cheap did it oh the
green light
[ __ ]
oh
god your window
this is like disneyland
[Music]
this is fun we have to bring the kids
here oh look it's different colors oh
it's a beautiful rainbow
you know what this is such a tourist
attraction this is the best twelve
dollars we've ever seen
well save your money chris looks like
the grandkids put their own twist on
things by hand washing the car
themselves
and it's cool to see the kardashian
kiddos having fun with the simple things
since we usually see them living their
best lives at over-the-top birthday
bashes
earlier this month court celebrated
penelope's 10th birthday with a pink
themed party we're just you know living
our best lives
and this year kim kardashian took north
to the woods for some glamping fun for
her ninth birthday so she wanted to have
a spooky wilderness themed
birthday party so i took them out
camping in the wilderness ready you're
ready girl
when north's guests weren't ziplining on
the camping trip they were getting a
makeup tutorial from the birthday girl
herself there was a whole class that she
taught her friends how to do
special effects wounds and scars she
really isn't to beauty well we're just
happy to see pee and north enjoying some
summertime fun even if it's not
disneyland
[Music]
my